two tennessee men are trying to bring
our country together
with a bike ride from coast to coast
andre block
senior and jonathan williams do not
agree on politics and they come from
very different backgrounds but they set
out on this
unity ride to prove everyone can find
something to agree on
no matter how many differences they may
have vlad duties spoke with them
after they finished their journey just
this past week vlad good morning again
good to see you again so from portland
maine to portland oregon
and everywhere in between these two men
a small business owner and a film
student
have cycled nearly 3 000 miles across
the united states in six and a half
weeks to bring attention
to one important idea
[Music]
the unity ride kind of came out of that
concept of
you know two people different
backgrounds different skin color
different political leanings
just set a common goal a lot could be
accomplished so
jonathan what do you talk about when
you're on these long rides together
a little bit everything we do get into
some very serious
heated conversations about a lot of
things we talk about america
we talk about immigration right we we
talk about politics in general right
yeah
uh we we talk about uh black lives
matter there are times when it's like
dude i adamantly disagree with you but
there's a lot of times when we
adamantly agree with one another the two
knoxville tennessee men became fast
friends after meeting at a new year's
eve party in 2015.
they've since embarked on a
cross-country journey together not
once not twice but three times
in d.c i think we're talking about
current issues road in the ride
but 2020's ride carries even greater
meaning for the duo
have you found um through your
discussions that you've been able
in some way to change each other's minds
about one particular thing
as a white american i don't necessarily
understand
some of the issues that black america
has with police
today first trip that we did together in
2017
andre was a little ahead of me on the
bike and i came up behind him
and there was a police cruiser right
around the corner
that it basically was stalking andre and
i didn't notice it i didn't see it
and i'm scared but that's the first one
that really made me
realize that hey this is a true
legitimate reaction
and a feeling that happens it's one of
the most profound moments of
our relationship to see him have that
understanding
poignant moments all along the way andre
and jonathan both carve out time for the
unity ride
supported by a couple of friends driving
an rv
all hoping to inspire others to share
some common ground
every time we get back together and get
on the bikes it is for the unity of our
country
and it feels so good to be able to get
this message out
andre and jonathan have experienced a
positive response and spark curiosity
and the people they've met along the way
the two hope to keep the unity ride
going
with another trip next year what was
really profound about that you all
remember that song walk a mile in my
shoes yes
that's what happened during that moment
yeah in real time and i love
such a moving story it's too bad he got
to see it but in a way i'm glad he got
to see it so yeah
that was the whole thing you better
understand because they understand each
other and what they see
i love that piece and i love that all
that began with a chance meeting at a
new year's eve party
exactly exactly nicely done mr duttier
thank you very much